[Music]
this is lavender heel as you can see
right now young people they're all young
some of them very young smashing in the
windows here of wind please this favor
the other side Ladbrokes head masters
hairdresser as well and from where I'm
standing here on Clapham Junction they
cannot see one policeman at all they're
all elsewhere in the city dealing with
problems elsewhere let's move up here
see what's happening this is quite
extraordinary every shot they could find
their looting where you guys up to is as
fun as it
then I'll go into headmasters the
hairdresser I mean this is just
extraordinary stuff
I've never seen this before I live down
there in town